men and women are not the same let me
tell you the difference between when men
do it and when women do
it and you can you can write your
comments in there as you see
fit when women step out they betray the
man when men step out they cheat there's
a
difference so again women prioritize the
best that they can get that's their
sexual strategy do you understand
hypergamy men prioritize availability so
she's hot she's willing let's go okay
again these are very different sexual
strategies in fact the entire red pill
the entire manow swamp can be subbed up
with those two lines I think Carl
summarized it that way before he left
the Manos swamp many many moons ago he
wrote in a blog women prioritize the
best that they can do men prioritize
availability totally different
strategies so when men step out it's
cheating when women step out it's
betrayal because women form a connection
with a guy when she steps out she has to
have an emotional connection it is
incredibly difficult for women just to
like run around and just like bang a
bunch of different guys and cheat on
their boyfriend there's some women that
are like unhinged chemically inbalance
and they're unhinged in that sense and
they do do that but most women generally
speaking if they're going to cheat on
you like if they're going to step out on
you or they are doing it right now
whether you're married it's Kevin and S
or the pool boy or whatever happens to
be uh they have formed an emotional
connection they have invested in this
other guy and they generally want to
Monkey Branch to him meaning they don't
want to leave the guy that they're with
until they can grab on to the next dude
before they release and they've got
their meat hooks they rarely deal with
two guys simultaneously and I can prove
it to you um ishmail the bloodthirsty
let's talk about him what the hell was
his real name Ismael ibben shif Mah
lived from 1672 to
1727 uh he was a Moroccan
Sultan and let's see so his spouse's
number 1 two 3 4 five 6 7 8 nine so he's
got 10 wives listed on his Wikipedia
page uh apparently he sired over a
thousand children oh wait it says right
here amongst 525 sons and 343 daughters
and he had concubines right so what he
would basically do is he'd obviously
have his wives and then he have his side
pieces or the concubines or whatever and
he'd have children with all of them and
what would generally happen is as they
got older as they all got older
obviously um he would start to retire
them and they would be responsible for
for child care and new ones would come
in which he would sleep with and
impregnate and they would he would just
continue the cycle until he had all
these children so he's Left Behind uh I
mean I've heard accounts of over a
thousand but it says 525 Sons 343
daughters on the Wikipedia page
today there is no example in history of
a woman doing that with men there's no
it just doesn't exist this guy had
hundreds of women he would actually turn
his guards into
Unix cut them off they would become Unix
and they would guard his women and he
did that so that the guards would not
touch his women and their job was of
course you know form a pimer protect
what's mine and keep everybody away from
it because that's all mine because I'm
going to be having children with all of
that all the time so you go back in the
historical records there's no example of
any women doing that at any given time
there's there's some examples of some
powerful women like you know Cleopatra
who would monkey Branch from dude to
dude sort of thing but nothing in the
sense where it was like hundreds and
hundreds of men simultaneously right men
can have thousands of children with
multiple women the world record for
women having children I think is
something like 63 it's in the 60s it's
like a ridiculous number and it was
sequential like quadruplets uh
sixtuplets uh twins like every single
pregnancy resulted in multiple children
simultaneously so the world record for a
woman is like 60 or something like that
for a dude it's like into the thousands
I mean you go to gangas Khan I think
something like one or two% of the
world's population today can be
genetically traced back to gangas Khan
it is what it is right so there's so
there's a massive difference between men
and women when it comes to sex sexual in
again women one egg men millions of
sperm sexual strategy for women
prioritize the best they can get men
prioritize availability right when a
woman steps out it's betrayal she is
betraying her commitment to that man she
is already looking at another guy as a
better option and thinking to herself
that's it I like Kevin from sales I'm
not really sure what's going on with
this guy but I think I'm going to find a
way out and I'm going to Monkey Branch
my way
over it could be under the radar it
could be somebody of lower value that's
more of a Chad more of like an alpha
dude and husband's like a beta male stay
at home you know makes makes money you
know makes Bank uh she wants to keep
them around maybe she's got kids with
them that's why you see these new age
open relationships showing up a lot on
dating sites where like married women
are all like I have an open relationship
with my husband so I can go bang what
whatever the hell I want cuz he's some
dork that's staying at home babysitting
the kids and probably making all the
money and she doesn't want to jeopardize
any of that um and she just wants some
fun on the side with some Chad or some
younger dude right so big big
differences and you know she can go out
there and have those romantic interests
because dude's paying the bills she's
just not that interested in them anymore
like she'll actually deal with the two
guys because you got alpha fox and beta
bucks over here same equation right that
doesn't exist for men no Alpha foxs Beta
bucks for men and women men just look at
women and go like I like that I think
I'd hit it right
she's walking away I think I'd wear that
ass as a hat that's that's that's very
nice right like like this is how men
operate we look at women as visually be
beautiful you know sexual objects right
so when we step out on somebody that
we've committed to it's cheating it's
not as significant as betrayal betrayal
is very significant to a guy cheating is
not as significant now men and women get
jealous for different reasons when it
comes to cheating which is also very
interesting too so make sure you're
taking some notes because we're going to
get deep deep down the rabbit hole
fellas so this is what women worry about
when a guy steps out this is what makes
them jealous right so if a guy goes off
and gets some exercise he steps out
comes home loves his family all this and
that and the other thing what she's
concerned about she doesn't start with
did you have sex with her how many times
did you have sex with her what did you
do when you had sex with her you know
what she starts with did you love her
do you have an emotional attachment to
her do you love her that's what she
wants to know when a chick steps out on
a guy and then they sit down and they
start having the conversation sitting at
a table like Will Smith and Jada pck
Smith did when Jada went off and banged
her son's best friend and will had to
sit there like a cuck listening to this
[__] the questions that they start
asking is did you [__] him how was the
sex did he make you come how many times
did you do it did he give you oral
like they start thinking all of these
things again men and women are very
different we think very differently the
reason why women get so pissed off at
guys and so hurt is because and again
their solipsism will never let them see
Pastor own NOS so women watching this
right now I'm gonna I'm gonna offer some
nuggets of wisdom and and truth you may
not like it I don't give a [__] it's the
reality of the
world you you just can't see pasture own
noses it's it's a feature not a bug
we're you know we love you for it women
are are concerned with you taking away
from her and her Offspring resources and
attention and
protection because you go back 250,000
years roaming around as nomadic H
gatherers there was no religion there
was no marriage there was no Pyramids of
Giza there was no gockley as far as you
know anyway there was none of that stuff
we would just roam around as nomadic
hunter gatherers and if a guy that she
had a connection with that she appear on
with or had children with that she was
sexually interested in and sharing her
body with would leave then it could
spell certain Doom for a woman like that
right because he's the one bringing home
the bacon he's the one that's protecting
everybody if the enemies knock on their
door let's have some more right they're
not picking up the war AES
they're not picking up the war axes and
having a fight the dudes are picking up
the war axes and they're going to battle
not the women remember
that so women's concern
is what if he takes protection resources
food and all the good stuff away from me
I'm going to have a hard time surviving
do women need a man today no they keep
saying woman needs a man like a fish
needs a bicycle so women's like biology
is always conflicting with this toxic
feminist narrative that's like you don't
need no man girl you go girl you know
sort of thing I'm that corporate lagger
put off having a family smash a bunch of
dudes right behave like a dude
right so women get incredibly hurt and
frustrated with a guy that steps out
because they think the way that they
think they apply their thinking to our
thinking which is [__] because that's
not how we think at all a man can legit
go out love his family love his children
pay for his house and everything I've
seen this I I coach High net worth
individuals athletes actors influencers
businessmen entrepreneurs I've dealt
with some very very interesting
people I know guys that have stepped out
on their marriage hundreds of times but
they still love their wife they still
love their children they still come home
they still pay the bills they still
protect they still preside they still go
all the family functions they go to the
the picnics and the thanksgivings and
the Christmas and the travels and the
summer holidays and all that [__] but he
goes out and gets exercise from time to
time I'm going to tell you something
that's very controversial I'll die on
this [__] Hill women that leave
men that love their family and pay for
everything because he steps out and are
all hurt they're selfish they are the
most selfish people on the planet
because they destroy that family they
tear that child that those those those
children apart um the father loses
access she steals resources from from
him as a consequence of that I know
athletes right now now that during their
career a-level athletes like we're
talking World Series champions NFL like
you know cup stuff okay that during
their career traveled around and women
throw themselves at them they just do
and every once in a while they stepped
out and they had some
fun when the women found out after they
retired they usually wait till after
they retired so they can get the maximum
benefits depending on what state they
live in but after they retired they wait
and then they divorce him you cheated on
me because they think the way that they
cheat is the way he's cheating like he
loves her he wants to be with her he's
choosing her over her instead and
resources and protection and all this s
sort of stuff is going to go over here
right so because women betray they think
that's a betrayal not just exercise not
just a little bit of side action they
think that that betrayal is exactly how
they behave they apply their thinking
their logic to him and these women are
the most self selfish women on the
planet I'm telling you right now
disgusting they disgust me when they
tear apart families when these men want
to be with their children and love their
family oh then why then why do they step
out that's wrong they shouldn't do
that if they weren't worldclass athletes
chasing exing putting a massive dent in
Universe with stadiums filled with
millions of people cheering them on if
they became fat incompetent losers
sitting at home they couldn't hold down
to job these same women would leave
those exact same men and go and Bank
somebody
else are you unplugging and seeing the
code in The Matrix men and women are
very different in how we operate and
this is just one example out of dozens
upon dozens that I could present to you
that Define the differences between
cheating and betrayal with men and women
I really hope you guys enjoyed that clip
if you want to watch the full length
podcast you can find that over here that
clips from if you're new to the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and pin down below in the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supplement line books and
a bunch of other stuff have an amazing
day peace out